hello and welcome to Rochford district
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residents this is the
summer 2014 edition in this edition are
articles on 82,000 pounds of National
Lottery funding to boost fitness
wallasey island nature lovers paradise
your local councillors the future of
Market Square dress to impress the
popularity of social media free home
safety checks and much more but we'll
begin with news of the recent wild woods
day family fun in the woods hockley
Woods was packed with families having
fun as Rochford District Council hosted
its 11th wild woods day family favorites
such as the climbing wall and archery
were back again this year and were
joined by a number of new activities
such as axe throwing rope bridge
building and a pop-up tourist
information center there were also a
number of new catering outlets including
a delicious hog roast and fresh Italian
coffee stand which went down a treat
with the crowds the event was also one
of the first official engagements for
Rochford District Council's newly
appointed chairman counselor June Lumley
who joined the crowds of enthusiastic
families and even tried her hand at some
of the activities on offer also in
attendance was the famous recycling
mascot Max the dragon who was on hand to
high five the youngsters and posed for
photographs and the Chairman's delight
at the wildwoods day the first official
engagement for Rochford District
Council's new chairman was to attend the
action-packed wildwoods day council the
jun lung they joined hundreds of
enthusiastic families in hockley woods
to try out activities including
geocaching archery and crafts while the
sound of live music echoed through the
trees the chairman said I'm delighted to
see so many families who weren't put off
by the early morning showers and came
along to enjoy a day out together it's
good to see new events this year such as
the axe throwing many more stores and
the tourist information pop-up store
which shows what our beautiful district
has to offer
I'd like to thank all the people who
have made this event such a success
could you help a family the family peer
mentoring service is looking for special
individuals with parenting or family
experience to become volunteer peer
mentors and make a difference to other
families in south essex full training
and ongoing support will be provided
enabling them to help families facing
significant challenges in their everyday
lives the volunteers will be carefully
matched with a family who they will
support for six months or more to get
their lives back on track and be better
placed to deal with future challenges by
themselves or with minimal outside
assistance families will be encouraged
to access services which are readily
available in the local community such as
after-school clubs libraries etc and
possibly go on to become future
volunteers each family will be facing
different problems and there may be
occasions where volunteers work together
each supporting different individuals
within the family unit if you feel you
have the understanding and passion for
helping a family to maintain a stable
home life we would like to hear from you
volunteers are needed to support
families across Rochford raley castle
point and basildon for more information
please contact ravs that's really
Rochford and district Volunteer Center
on 01 268 double 727 96 or you can email
volunteering at ravs co uk Rochford and
rayleigh Citizens Advice Bureau would
like to hear about your experiences with
Employment Support Allowance and in
particular obtaining reliable medical
evidence please contact us if you'd like
to discuss your situation the Citizens
Advice Bureau offers free confidential
advice on a
range of issues at Rochford office back
lane rochford SS 41 a why on tuesdays
and thursdays between 10am and 2 p.m. or
at the rayleigh office which is at civic
sweet hockley road rayleigh SS 680 be on
Mondays Thursdays and Fridays again
between 10 and 2 p.m. there's a phone
service available on 0844 for double 70
80 8 and those phones are manned between
monday to friday 930 a.m. to four p.m.
volunteering with the CA b is a great
way to pick up skills make friends and
feel part of an enthusiastic team
whether you're at school or retired
working or job hunting there's a
rewarding role at your local CA B we
currently have a number of opportunities
for people to get involved to find out
more contact 0787 6470 one double o
registering to vote the way you register
to vote has changed the new system means
you can now register online each
individual is responsible for
registering themselves this can no
longer be done by another householder
more details are required including
national insurance number and date of
birth most people who registered to vote
before june the 10th 2014 have been
automatically transferred to the new
system and do not need to do anything
however if you have moved since then you
will need to register under the new
system registering to vote is easy go to
www k /o gesture hyphen tow hyphen vote
if you have any questions contact
Rochford district councils elections
team on 0 1 702 318 187 or email
elections at Rochford gov k children
take your cue it's show time
rochford District Council's family
theater events at the mill arts & Events
Center in rayleigh are so popular that
even more shows have been added so that
families can continue to enjoy the
theater experience locally following on
from the sold-out spring performances
booking has opened for the summer season
aimed at families with children aged two
to eight years old these shows are a
great theater taster but be quick as
tickets sell out very quickly the
performance details at two o'clock on
sunday afternoon sep tember the 21st is
a show that's entitled you're not my
friend anymore also at two o'clock on
sunday october the 12th fireside tales
with granddad and at 11am and 2 p.m. on
sunday november the ninth the magic
porridge pot Rochford district councils
head of community services jeremy born
said it is fantastic that so many
families are now getting the chance to
go to theater without even needing to
leave the district these productions are
run by professional theatre companies
who deliver top quality performances at
amazingly affordable prices it's a real
treat for any family and accompanying
this article are two lovely photographs
of two little boys and this is what they
had to say Calum Philpott who comes from
rayleigh said i really liked the puppets
especially the octopus and the shark
they really made me jump and Joseph
Johnson who is also from Raley said I
really enjoyed it and I want to come
back and see even more shows and tickets
for all of those shows are on sale now
they cost just three pounds fifty each
by calling our customer services team
0170 2318 191 that's during office hours
only but if you'd like more information
please visit www k
forward slash arts it's time to nominate
for the Rochford and castlepoint sports
awards 2014 sponsored by pinnacle PSG
contenders are needed for the following
categories sports personality of the
year young sports personality of the
year disability sports personality of
the year sports club of the year
services to sport and 2012 respect thank
you to sponsors Wells legal solicitors
waters and Stanton limited Southend
United CET the co-operative funeralcare
fusion lifestyle and affinity 1777 you
can submit nominations at WWE our govt
UK forward slash sports awards or you
can phone a 170 2318 121 and for a copy
of the form email sport at Rochford
gavotte UK an 82,000 pound National
Lottery funding boost is set to help
workforces in rochford and Castle Point
get fit and healthy the cash injection
will be provided by sports England's
community sport activation fund over the
next three years to launch an active
colleagues project the scheme
facilitated by Rochford District Council
castlepoint Borough Council active
Rochford and active castlepoint enables
local companies to offer free sports
sessions to staff in the first year
sessions will be offered to staff at six
locations with others following suit in
years two and three rochford District
Council's portfolio holder for community
councillor Joe McPherson said I'm
delighted to be involved with the scheme
is very important that everyone has the
chance to participate in sporting
activities hopefully by encouraging this
in the workplace it will give even more
people the incentive to get fit and
improve their overall well-being Mike
diaper
Sport England director of community
sport said it's great to be working with
innovative projects like active
colleagues to offer people the chance to
get into sport in a way that best suits
then the investment being made through
the community sport activation fund is
making a real difference at a very local
level 100 budding musicians have taken
part in a new project which has just
received a funding boost the project
called a student-led music ensembles
enables children to create original
music pieces and then share them with
their peers it sees talented young
people from fits while Mark secondary
school given the opportunity to mentor
young musicians from six rayleigh
primary schools in turn they become role
models and develop key leadership skills
the project has been running since last
autumn and was initially funded by the
essex music education hub royal opera
house bridge rochford district council
and Rochford extended services it has
now received additional funding from the
essex music education hub which will
enable extra music sessions to be
arranged the impact the project is
having will be recorded and
best-practice shared with others
rochford District Council's head of
community services Jeremy born said much
that now has the most advanced youth
music leader project in Essex he added
rochford is really leading the way in
supporting young people to develop
transferable skills in music leadership
and decision-making Direct Debit for
council tax and business rates easy as
123 paying your bill by direct debit
cuts out unnecessary payment journeys
saving you time money checks and stamps
direct debit is convenient for you and
good for the environment you can pick a
payment plan to suit your budget
ensuring payments are made on time and
avoiding the hassle of reminders and
extra costs with direct debit monthly
amar
are automatically deducted from your
bank account you can choose from three
monthly payment dates over 12 10 or 12
installments to suit your budget and you
can select from one of three dates each
month from when those payments will be
taken out the first the tenth and the
20th of the month applying for direct
debit could not be easier you can visit
w wh fo govt UK forward slash council
tax or when it comes to business rates
WWE are a govt UK forward slash business
rates to set up online or phone us on 0
1 702 318 197 or 0 1 702 318 198 now for
some business rates updates on December
the 5th 2013 the Chancellor announced
the following changes to business rates
in 2014-15 the extension of a hundred
percent small business rates relief for
properties with a rateable value of less
than 6,000 pounds and that's up until
March 2015 all businesses have the
option to pay their business rates over
12 months a discount of up to 1,000
pounds will be available to all occupied
retail properties with a rateable value
of 50,000 pounds or less a fifty percent
discount for 18 months for businesses
that move into retail premises after the
first of april 2014 if they have been
empty for a year or more please don't
forget to tell us about any changes that
could affect your council tax
if you get a council tax exemption or
discount or are entitled to council tax
support you must tell us about any
change in your circumstances that could
affect these we need to be told about
any change within 21 days of it
happening if not we can impose a penalty
of 70 pounds which will be added to your
council tax bill it is important that
when you contact us the information you
give us includes details of the change
and the date it happened you can tell us
about changes by phoning us on Oh 1702
318 197 or 318 198 monday to friday
between 8am and 6pm writing to us at
council offices South Street rochford
Essex ss4 1bw visiting us between monday
to thursday 830am 25 30 p.m. and friday
830am 2 5pm or you could email us
revenues and benefits at Rochford
dot-gov dot UK and please remember we do
need to be told about any change within
21 days of it happening nature lovers
paradise a major project is underway to
create Europe's largest intertidal
habitat a nature lovers paradise which
is taking shape right on our very
doorstep one of the many phases of the
wallasey wild coast project is set to
open to the public in spring or summer
2015 and this will be your first chance
to see what will become an important new
visitor attraction by then it's
anticipated the first of two say line
legumes will have been created
attracting waders and wild fowl to the
site these lagoons will eventually be
complemented by a series of mud flats
salt marsh and brackish marsh
which will transform the island located
off kinnunen into a 700 hectare
sanctuary for wildlife the project is
being run by the RSPB who are planning
to achieve this feat by using breaches
or holes in the sea wall to allow the
sea in to recreate intertidal habitats
but first they must use soil to raise
the height of the land so far Crossrail
has shipped in 1.8 million tons of soil
to assist this mammoth undertaking
eventually they'll be almost enough to
fill Wembley Stadium twice from top to
bottom Rachel fancy the warden of
wallasey Island said it's the only
project of its type because of the land
raising and managed realignment these
two things have never been done on this
scale in the UK or even in Europe this
scheme will mean Wallace the island will
return to a state much like how it was
in days gone by when it was made up of
five saltmarsh islands before it was
enclosed by the current sea walls more
importantly it should attract a whole
array of rare birds by the time it's
completed in about 20-25 including
black-winged stilts which are scarce
along the Essex Coast the ideal aim
would be to attract some breeding
spoonbills as we can create some nice
undisturbed conditions for them said
Rachel it's only in the last four years
that these have returned to the UK to
breed after a gap of over 300 years it's
hoped the birds will be attracted by
Wallace's mud which will be so rich in
nutrients that one meter cubed will
contain the same number of calories as
16 Mars bars Rachel added I think it's a
brilliant place locally for people in
the Rochford district and Southend to
have on their doorstep and it should be
a good site for people to come and visit
from miles away well as the wild coast
project vital statistics about 4 million
tons of soil will be shipped in by cross
rail this equates to 40,000 tons a week
it will encourage the growth of
nationally scarce plant species
associate
disturbed brackish conditions such as
curved hard grass sea clover stiff salt
marsh grass and see barley water voles
and brown hair are important mammals on
site a range of invertebrates can be
spotted on the dry grassland these will
include black oil beetles and solitary
bumblebees in winter you may see
wonderful views of Brent Pease lovers
lapwing dunlin godwits and not if you're
lucky you may see snow bunting lort
white the hope is to also attract
breeding birds including avocet redshank
ringed plover Skylark read bunting corn
bunting Comintern and yellow wagtail
exploring open spaces hello and welcome
to the new open spaces section of
Rochford district matters each seasonal
addition will bring the opportunity to
discover a little more about your local
woods Parks and Wildlife there will also
be an in-focus section with fascinating
facts focused around a wild plant or
creature in the early 20th century the
then rochford rural district council
said about preserving by purchase much
of the local woodland and parks we enjoy
today in the 21st century this
commitment continues with the creation
of Swain and cherry orchard jubilee
country parks the woodlands and open
spaces team are a small but dedicated
bunch who manage maintain and operate a
wide range of services across the
district these include hockley bets
grove kingly and New England woods Swain
and cherry orchard jubilee country parks
cutting of grass verges sports pitches
and public parks the preservation and
health of local trees and arboriculture
maintenance works safety inspections and
maintenance of playgrounds burials and
maintenance of cemeteries and
churchyards the health and welfare of
animals and birds the team would like to
thank local residents and friends groups
for their continued support and if you'd
like to contact the team please phone
customer services on 0 1 702 3181 double
one who would be happy to help
alternatively visit the council's
website for more information in focus
the skylark in fine voice for summer
this piece is written by Richard bond
woodland and open spaces supervisor this
summer we find ourselves a centurion
from the First World War and for me the
Skylark song is both a sound of summer
and one of remembrance during the First
World War this plucky little bird
remained on the battlefield in soldiers
letters homes from the front they
described how in the brief rest from
shelling and gunfire the little lark
would ascend his song bringing a moment
of tranquillity to both sides of the
trench sadly this little bird is in
decline the period between 1972 and 1996
saw the loss of 75 percent of the UK
breeding population changes to farming
practices have seen a lack of suitable
nesting habitat allowing the birds only
a small chance of raising a successful
brood of chicks some farms are now
creating suitable habitats by leaving
unseeded areas of 5 to 10 meters around
the centre of arable fields preferring
short vegetation and areas of grasses in
which it can forage for food the Skylark
finds refuge in the quiet areas of our
country parks many of the district's
open spaces provide this habitat and
enable the birds to have a better chance
of successful breeding male birds can
climb as high as a hundred metres above
the fields singing initially to attract
a mate then after to defend his
territory the song will last for a few
minutes but later in the season this can
exceed 20 minutes being a ground nesting
bird both male and female will sing to
attract attention away
for the nest running along the ground
first before taking flight singing
defiantly when predators approach three
to six eggs are laid in June and a
second or third brood may be started
later in the year the eggs are colored
yellow and white with brownish purple
spots at the large end a good mimic the
Skylark will often include within its
own song the cause of other birds that
share the local area so when you're out
next take a moment lie back enjoy the
larks sweet summer song and remember
boosting business growth the first
business summit has been held by
Rochford District Council to pick start
plans for economic growth in the area
the event was hosted by the council's
economic development team which provides
local businesses with ongoing support
and advice attendees had the chance to
shape the economic growth strategy that
will drive forward investment
opportunities over the next three years
Sean scrutton Rochford District
Council's head of planning and
transportation said our aim is to engage
in a healthy dialogue with businesses
regarding their priorities our
priorities and how we can work together
to build a stronger economy for the
rajma district the Rochford district
growth strategy is vital because it will
encourage investment innovation and be
the driving force to strengthen and
build upon the entrepreneurial character
of the district this year's first to
watch for district business breakfasts
have also taken place with the next one
set for Thursday October the 9th the
networking events run in partnership
with the Federation of small businesses
and low-carbon business are a chance to
hear about developments in the Rockford
district which could provide
opportunities for economic growth CLE
speakers have included Susan ROM
director act biz fit sarahbelle
innovation and sector development
manager at invest Essex and Jim
Wilkinson skills manager at Essex County
Council Rochford district council's
chief executive mr dave said these
business breakfasts are
means for local businesses to network
and to find out what support is on offer
and how watch the district council and
its partners can assist local business
growth local business owner and chair of
hot key chamber of trade Jeff Stanton of
waters and Stanton who attended the
event said I have been a long term
supporter of the business breakfasts
there is always something new to learn
and they are a good way of keeping up to
date with new business developments long
may they continue for more information
on these events and the support service
that the economic development team offer
visit w WH the govt UK /this your local
councillors there are 39 councillors
representing 19 Ward's or areas of the
district following the local elections
in May the political groupings within
the district council are as follows 27
conservative councillors forming a new
group and the largest opposition group
comprising four councillors to Green
Party and to Rockford residents
councillors three liberal Democrat
councillors three United Kingdom
Independence Party councillors one
independent conservative and one Labour
councillor elections for Essex County
Council also took place on the same day
there are five Essex County Council
electoral areas within the Rockford
district these areas are known as
divisions and one councillor represents
each area the five essex county council
representatives for the rockford
district are Raley North counselor
Malcolm Maddox conservative rayleigh
south consulate Keith Gibbs you Kip
Rochford North councillor Terry cut more
conservative Rochford south counselor
Colin sigas conservative and Rockford
West councillor michael hoy
green and these are the counselors in
your area ashington and canoodle mrs.
tjk pond and TG cut more both
conservative barling and sutton MJ
steptoe conservative down hall and roar
a--the see I black and Ra autumn both
lib dem foul nests and great wakering n
j-hook way you Kip cg segars
conservative and mrs. bj Wilkins
conservative grange J Burton you Kip and
mrs. JR Lumley lib dem and the current
chairman of the council Hall North mrs.
la butcher and mrs. je McPherson both
conservative awkward self p a cape on
and mrs. H la Glynn both conservative
hawk will West jrf Mason mrs. CM Mason
both Rochford District residents hockley
central KH Hudson mrs. C a weston and
BTW Hazelwood all conservative hockley
north mr carter conservative hockley
west em Maddox conservative hullbridge
em hoi and mrs de hoy both Green Party
and mrs. AV hail conservative lodge d
Merrick and IH Ward conservative and
rayleigh central mrs. MH Spencer and
mrs. C ero conservative in rochford mrs.
GA Lucas Gil and mr. k j gordon both
conservative and mr. Jacobson labor
Swain Park birth conservative
councillors mrs. J a mock furred and mr.
te mountain Trinity ward councillor DJ
sparing who is a conservative and J
hater are you Kip weekly Ward both
conservatives mr. JD Griffin and
jl lohrmann and in White House Ward
again to conservative councillors mr. RR
Dre and mr. SP Smith meet the new
chairman we're delighted to introduce
counselor mrs. June Lumley who is the
new chairman of Rochford district
council after being elected at the
annual council meeting on june the third
2014 the new vice chairman of the
council is counselor mrs. Heather Glynn
who will assist counselor mrs. Lumley
during her term counselor mrs. Lumley is
a district councillor for Ray League
range and has lived in the Rockford
district for 47 years she's married to
Chris until recently also a Rochford
district councillor and has three
daughters three granddaughters and two
grandsons two of her daughters and three
granddaughters living rayleigh and the
last daughter and two grandsons live in
australia councillor Lumley has been a
member of Rochford district councils
since 2002 representing rayleigh grange
ward she was chair of the review
committee for six years from 2007 and in
2013 she became vice chairman of the
council she is also chair of governors
of edward frances primary school in
rayleigh and the chair of the trustees
of three local charities in the district
councillor Lumley said after her
election as chairman of Rochford
district council I am honored to become
chairman of Rochford district council
and thank my fellow councillors for the
trust they have put in me by elected me
to the position in my year as chairman I
want to meet as many groups and
organizations as I can across the
district so that I can better understand
the valuable work that they do in
particular for people who are vulnerable
and need additional help and support to
improve the quality of their lives I
will not be naming any charities to
support until the end of my ear but they
will be local charities within the
Rockford district if you would like the
Chairman to attend an event you're
organizing or visit a group or
organization
you're part of please get in touch with
us details will be given later past
chairman honors our citizen of the year
rochford district council's annual
Citizen of the Year awards proved to be
yet another success as the then chairman
hosted a special event paying tribute to
some of the district's unsung heroes the
awards were held on 16th of may to
recognize and acknowledge residents from
within the Rockford district for their
valuable hard work generosity and
outstanding achievements this year's
nominations were divided into four
categories citizen of the year young
citizen charitable support and community
spirit nominations poured in for people
of all ages and in all categories and
the judges were hugely impressed with
the sheer amount of hard work and
dedication of those who contribute to
our community from helping out at a
local level supporting neighbors friends
and those in need through to our young
citizens who work hard at school and are
an inspiration to their peers after a
great deal of deliberation the judging
panel decided that the Citizen of the
Year award should be awarded to Martin
butler for his work with young people
Luke polly was named young citizen of
the year for raising a staggering amount
of money for last year's poppy appeal
the charitable support award went to
Janet Fox for her charity hope works and
the community spirit award to Lauren
scandal for creating mega Center a
valuable resource for people of all ages
within the wider community the former
chairman of Rochford District Council
Councillor Barbara Wilkins said I would
like to congratulate the winners but
also say a huge thank you to all the
other nominees who have achieved so much
and contributed to a community spirit we
can all be proud of without these
amazing people the district would not be
the wonderful place it is today to
contact the Chairman's office please
find the Civic Officer Lynn rectly on 0
1 702 3181 double for or email Lynn dot
rectly at Rochford got you K future of
Market Square how do we attract more
shoppers residents have been asked our
Rochford's Market Square could be
revitalized to make it more appealing to
shoppers the planning policy team set up
a stall on market day to talk directly
to residents shoppers and businesses
about what improvements could be made
they also displayed black-and-white
photographs illustrating the history of
the bustling market town including
pictures of the cattle market which used
to be held in the square though it's not
suggested that the reintroduction of a
cattle market would be an option and
accompanying this article are two
wonderful photographs those
black-and-white photographs showing
Rochford square as it used to be all
those years ago now this all formed part
of a public consultation on the square
which concluded on May the eight this
year the information will be fed back
into the Rockford area action plan a
document which will be used to guide and
manage development throughout Rochford
town center the draft area action plan
was submitted to the government for
independent examination in November 2013
and a hearing session was held on
februari the 19th this year before it
was decided that we needed to undertake
some further work to determine a way
forward for the square the council will
use the consultation to inform this
decision this along with other
modifications to the plan if accepted by
the inspector will then be consulted on
for a further six week period the
allocations plan allocates specific
sites which are suitable for future
development it includes sites for homes
businesses schools and open spaces this
plan does not automatically grant
consent for the land in question to be
developed but it is the council's view
that these sites are those most suitable
for development the plan is intended to
inform decision-making on planning
in the future the hockley area action
plan sets out detailed policies for
managing and guiding development in the
center of hockley both these documents
were adopted as a meeting of full
council on February the 25th 2014
following an independent examination by
the government planning inspector which
found them both to be sound the
allocations plan has since been subject
to a legal challenge by a local resident
which the council has instructed a
barrister to defend against however
despite this challenge the allocations
plan remains part of the local
development plan for the district and
planning applications can be submitted
on this basis unmanned exhibitions were
held throughout the district from March
the 3rd to the 15th 2014 for residents
to submit their questions about the
allocations plan these questions have
been collated and responses to a number
of the main issues can be viewed online
at www k a development management plan
has been drawn up which sets out the
detailed day-to-day policies which
planning applications will be assessed
against this includes policies for new
homes housing extension limits in the
greenbelt and equestrian facilities the
plan was submitted to the government for
independent examination in December 2013
and a hearing session was held on March
the 26th 2014 additional consultation on
proposed modifications to the plan will
take place for a six week period before
being submitted to the inspector for
consideration london southend airport
hopes for six thousand new jobs the
london Southend Airport and environment
area action plan has been prepared
jointly by Rochford District Council and
Southend Borough Council to respond to
the opportunities offered by the airport
and its surrounding area it is envisaged
plan will lead to the creation of about
six thousand new jobs through measures
including the provision of a new
business park it was submitted to the
government for independent examination
in December 2013 and hearing sessions to
discuss the issues raised by the
inspector commenced on April the 29th
2014 when your special day rainy
windmill is nearing its 200th wedding
booking to celebrate this Rochford
District Council are offering one lucky
couple the hire of rayleigh windmill
free of charge for their wedding to be
in with a chance of winning this
fantastic prize all you need to do is
book your ceremony at the windmill and
if you are lucky enough to be the 200th
booking you'll win your higher of the
windmill free of charge courtesy of
Roger District Council and we are not
stopping there anyone who makes a
booking before the 200th will also
receive a one-off discount of ten
percent of the higher charge but you
need to be quick the venue has proven to
be very popular with seating for up to
20 guests rayleigh windmill offers an
intimate venue for all civil ceremonies
and is situated next to a stunning
sensory garden and the historic rayleigh
mount you'll also have a dedicated event
coordinator who will ensure that your
special day runs perfectly the landmark
building 1 the 2014 national museums
plus heritage award for customer service
excellence conveniently it is also
located near to a host of reception
venues in rayleigh including the mill
arts & Events Center which is adjacent
to the windmill to find out more please
contact the lazer team at Rochford
district council on Oh 17025 463 double
6 or via email on leisure at Rochford
gov ok dress to impress have you ever
considered the value of your clothes the
love your clothes campaign aims to make
the most of the clothes we already have
and think about how we buy use and
dispose of our clothes the message was
taken to a whole new level
by civic college students who dressed
the window of the fab charity shop in
rayleigh high street entirely with
reused materials they created a dress
made of clothes pegs and there's a
picture accompanying this article yes
clothes pegs indeed they are used a
display using old records and even a
chandelier made from old forks now why
not visit love your clothes org UK to
find out how you can reuse materials to
make your clothes last longer reduce the
environmental impact of laundering your
clothes deal with unwanted clothes make
the most of your wardrobe this will help
reduce the impact on the environment by
reducing the amount of carbon water and
waste created through the manufacture
laundry and disposal of clothing it will
also help you save money the basic
principles are care for your clothes
choose clothes with easy care
technologies which dry quickly wash
clothing at 30 degrees wash clothing
correctly save up to a hundred and
thirty pounds a year by line drying your
clothes get creative create brand new
looks using the clothes you already own
create a fresh look repair it alter it
accessorize diet and personalize
clothing recycle your clothes even if
you've decided to part ways with some of
your clothing you can still pass it on
swapping with friends or family or
donating to charity gives your unwanted
items a new lease of life old or
unwanted reusable clothing can also be
placed out in blue essex textiles bags
beside your recyclables bin on your
recycling
Election Day for more information or for
a supply of bags call oh 800 787 9071
alternatively clothing footwear and
accessories can be placed into any of
the textile recycling banks located
around the Rochford district for a full
list of these visit w WH foods gov UK
forwards /recycling or call customer
services on 0 1 702 3181 double one
dispose of rubbish responsibly
fly-tipping is the illegal dumping of
waste punishable by imprisonment and up
to 50,000 pound fine on conviction every
year it costs vast sums of taxpayers
money to clear waste dumped illegally on
public land in the Rochford district
fly-tipping can seriously pollute water
courses and contaminate land it can be a
risk to human health and harm wildlife
and livestock it's unsightly and
encourages others to dump more waste
it's seen as a major problem by over
three-quarters of landowners it
undermines legitimate waste management
companies who are undercut by illegal
operators please ensure that only people
who will dispose of your waist
responsibly are allowed to take it away
you can ask to see their waste carriers
registration details and these can be
checked online at www k and follow the
links if you see someone you suspect of
fly-tipping please report it to the
council by calling customer services on
0 1 702 3181 double one never been done
before the pioneering social experiment
is taking place in rayleigh which has
never been tried anywhere before the
charity bins campaign aims to prevent
littering while helping good causes and
you can play your
part it's all part of a three-month
project which will see Rochford district
council team up with the wrigley company
and keep britain tidy to find out if
social good can motivate people to put
litter in the bin from joan bins in
rayleigh high street have turned into
charity bins and three local good causes
will benefit this will be wyvern
community transport which provides
low-cost transport for permanent
residents of the rockford district and
castle point Boro who are unable to use
conventional public transport the
mushroom theatre company which strives
to promote inclusion in performing arts
and in society in general and rarely
Rochford in district association for
voluntary services revs which supports
them promotes charities and volunteering
in the district every time people put
their litter in the bin rather than
dropping it on the ground they will help
these charities get a bigger share of a
1,500 pounds pot if it reduces littering
the scheme could be rolled out across
the UK so look out for the bins and help
your local charities at the same time
are you eco-friendly a rethink rubbish
event is being held this autumn and we
are looking for input from local
businesses and individuals do you reuse
and recycle old items and create fun
quirky new things that you use or sell
if so we want you to be part of our
event the event will be held at the mill
Arts & Event Center raley on Thursday
October the 30th this year and will
showcase all things reuse and recycled
it will be a celebration of the fact
that Rochford District Council has been
named the number one Authority in the
country after the department for
environment food and rural affairs
revealed we had the top recycling rate
in the whole of England at sixty six
point eight two percent for 2012-13 we
to thank residents for this amazing
achievement as it could not have been
done without your help we hope this
event will explore new ways residents
can reduce reuse and recycle waste there
will be performances from the mushroom
theatre company recycled arts and crafts
live needlework demonstrations
information stands a recycled fashion
show and much more so for more
information and to register your
interest please call the customer
services 0170 2318 one double one or
email recycling at Rochford gov dot uk'
joining forces to tackle litter street
cleansing alone costs taxpayers over
800,000 pounds each year in rochford
district the social and environmental
costs take that figure even higher as do
the costs to business and tourism we
know through consultation that cleaner
streets parks and open spaces are
important to you but with ever
decreasing budgets keeping these areas
clean and tidy is becoming a greater
challenge in the fight against litter we
have joined forces with all the essex
local authorities essex county council
all McDonald's and KFC restaurants in
essex dominos pizzas the helping hand
company the highways agency Rathburn
media and BBC radio essex to deliver a
campaign to tackle littering Phil Barton
chief executive of keep britain tidy
says the clean essex partnership where
local authorities businesses and
communities are working together to
tackle the problem of litter is setting
a fantastic example no single
organization can solve the problem of
litter in isolation and to see this
group run a campaign across the county
is exactly what we need to see at a
regional and national level essex has
realized that by coming together they
can make a difference and we
commend them for their leadership and
focus join us in the fight if you see a
heavily littered area or someone
littering it report it you can do so
these ways wewt a govt UK by email
customer services at Rochford gavel UK
you can telephone 0170 2318 one double
one or use the sita Rochford love clean
streets mobile app out and about who
what when where and how clubs and groups
south in way doke I traditional way doe
Ryu keeping up the original teachings of
its founder hironori otsuka this is on
Mondays seven o'clock great wakering
Memorial Hall seven o'clock on fridays
at San andrew's church hall in ashington
contact Tony brooker Oh 780 679 5967
active 50 plus a fun exercise session
for all abilities to increase the heart
rate and tone this is 930 on fridays at
hook will baptist church for pound per
session no need to book just come along
and join in contact sarah on active life
Oh double 740 626 two to six ww active
life UK com Nordic Walking a fun walking
session using polls to increase your
workout no experience necessary this is
a lemon o'clock on tuesdays at Cherry
Orchard Jubilee country park booking is
essential contact tina active life Oh
double 758 double 239 double five or www
active life UK com Fitz why mark
badminton club is anxious to recruit
experienced players 730 until
nine-thirty every Monday evening this is
at the David Cox sports hall Fitz why
marks school in rayleigh contact might
worship on 01 268
47 1914 or worships at talktalk dot net
the roach art group all abilities
catered for at this friendly club with
good lighting on facilities and a
variety of media this is between
seven-thirty and 9 30 p.m. on wednesday
evenings at st. Theresa's church hall in
ashington Rover Oxford ss4 1rf entrances
via the school gates with the hall
located to the rear of the church these
this is reasonable fees apply and
details on request contact John on 079
double 3263 930 there are further art
classes available for beginners and more
experienced students between 10am and
12pm and 1pm till 3 p.m. mondays and
tuesdays these are held at Women's
Institute hall in bellingham Lane
rayleigh contact 0170 2615 475 or Paul
okok 43 at yahoo co uk council and
committee meetings all meetings will
take place at the civic sweet to hotly
road rally in essex ss6 atb and they all
start at seven thirty p.m. the
development committee first did you I
the 24th and full council on tuesday
July the 29th for information contact
member services on 0 1 702 318 140 dates
for your diary summer holiday activities
from July the 23rd to August the 29th
really windmill heritage open days
September thirteenth and fourteenth the
Rochford art trail September the 18th to
the 27th there'll be some half-term
holiday activities between October the
27th and the 31st and Rochford and
Castle Point sports awards on November
the 6th some events to take note of
family bowling day
is why don't you come along as a family
and learn to play bowls you can do it on
Sunday the 31st of August and sunday the
sep tember the 14th at half-past two in
the afternoon that's at the Rochford
bowling club and you need to contact
jackie Swan on Oh 170 278 1262 Family
Theater professional theatre shows for
children and families fun entertaining
and affordable September the 21st 2 p.m.
that's a sunday you're not my friend
anymore also at two p.m. but on Sunday
the 12th of October fireside tales with
granddad 11 a.m. & 2pm sunday november
the 9th the magic porridge pot and this
all happens that the mill arts an event
center in rayleigh it's three pounds
fifty a ticket and the booking is via
Rochford district councils customer
services department 0170 2318 191 and
please note that although events are
checked before going to press their
subject to change so we recommend that
you visit our website w WAW k or contact
the organizers to check before going to
an event have your say on Rochford
district matters we are reviewing the
content of Rochford district matters and
we're keen to know what you would like
to see in your council newspaper do you
like the current format should we change
the name is it too short or too long is
there something missing that you would
really like to see included you can send
any ideas about how Rochford district
matters could be improved you can send
any ideas about how Rochford district
matters could be improved by emailing
communications at Rochford gov UK via
twitter at Rochford DC or in writing
communications team rochford District
Council South Street Rochford SS 41 b w
think before you post the popularity of
social media has really taken off since
Facebook was first launched in February
2004 for many social networking is now
as natural as having a face to face chat
however the community safety team has
seen a rise in intimidating comments and
threats being posted and reported to
them bullying UK suggests don't get into
arguments online this is called flaming
and it can get nasty if you break the
rules of which ever site you're on then
the content is likely to be removed and
you might have your membership
terminated you're not allowed to upload
anything which is offensive or racist
and which promotes physical harm so
don't make threats to anyone most social
networking sites have rules which
prohibit abusive behaviors that includes
bullying harassment impersonation and
identity theft on the bullying UK
website there are details about how to
make a complaint you should copy the
terms and conditions of that particular
social networking site which have been
breached and take a screenshot of the
comment or photo as evidence use the
reporting process outlined at www NGO UK
and follow the links the popularity of
selfies the practice of taking a photo
of yourself and all others and then
posting them onto social networks has
recently seen the Pope posing outside
the Vatican at Easter and President
Obama and David Cameron at the memorial
service for Nelson Mandela for many
these are fun and harmless images but
for others what is posted can be much
more sinister a trend to text naked
images to someone special which are then
posted by the receiver on a social
networking site can cause all sorts of
implications and it could be illegal
depending on the age of the person
involved it is important to be aware
that an adult or young person involved
in sharing sexual videos and pictures
may be committing a criminal offence
specifically crimes involving indecent
photographs of a person under 18 years
of age fall under section one of the
protection of children at 1978 and
section 160 of the Criminal Justice Act
1988 under this legislation it is a
crime to take an indecent photograph or
allow an indecent photograph to be taken
to make an indecent photograph that
includes downloading or opening an image
that has been sent via email distribute
or show such an image possess with the
intention of distributing images
advertise and possess such images an off
com survey in 2011 showed forty-one
percent of young people between 12 and
15 had a smartphone statistics from the
children's charity beat bullying 3
suggests that thirty-eight percent had
received a sexually explicit text or
email while twenty-five percent had
received an offensive sexual image if
you are concerned that your child or a
young person known to you has been
affected by such actions you can seek
advice at wwt q no co uk a community
speed watch has been launched to
accurately capture speed data on some of
our local roads to start to address
concerns being raised about road safety
issues these are now active in canada na
chinden Rochford and Stanbridge if you
can spare one to two hours a month and
are interested in being involved in
these areas please contact PC Michelle
rawson at Raley police station Michelle
rawson at Essex dot pnn dr. police UK or
phone 101 extension for 90
535 remember watch your speed free home
safety checks for eligible Rochford
District residents as part of the free
home safety checks Trading Standards
officers carried out portable appliance
testing or pat testing on small domestic
appliances including kettles toasters
slow cookers ions and heaters in order
to prevent and reduce accidental
dwelling fires any item that failed the
Pat test was fixed or replaced free of
charge which ensured residents were not
left without essential appliances the
community safety team in partnership
with Essex County Council Trading
Standards will be holding a series of
free one day home safety checks
throughout this year to be eligible for
a free home safety check you must be
aged over 65 years or require additional
support due to a learning disability or
mental physical or sensory impairment if
you meet the criteria and would like to
be included in a future free home safety
check please email Community Safety at
Rochford gov UK or phone Sophie manners
on 0 1 702 318 120 rochford district
matters is designed and published by
Roger District Council its editor is
Laura bliss the telephone number for the
council is 0 17025 463 double 6 the
magazine is printed by Morton
print--limited 01 50 75 2 3 4 5 6 this
recording has been produced by
volunteers from the rayleigh Rochford
and castlepoint talking newspaper